en somme ensemble commerçants
agriculteurs chômeurs personnels de
santé éducation et de nombreux autres
secteurs venus dire non à la réforme des
retraites mais aussi dans la rue de
nombreuses autres revendications mais
aussi contre les suppressions d'emplois
contre les licenciements pour une
augmentation significative des salaires
vous qu'on a un salaire minimum dans
1800 euros nets contre le démantèlement
de la sécurité sociale contre le
démantèlement du code du travail contre
toute une série de mesures demandées par
le patronat est mise en application par
le gouvernement dans les rangs des
manifestants il y avait aussi des
retraités mobilisés car il pourrait
comme les travailleurs être impacté le
projet qui ont travaillé et ceux qui
travaillent toujours leur réforme
criminel parle tout le temps je ne sais
pas si je me demandais si google s'est
lui doit la vérité mais ensuite et
variable en fonction du coût de la dette
à des aigus diminuer ces prochaines
semaines diront si le gouvernement
entendra ces protestations et reviendra
sur ce projet de réforme des retraites